when you walk out of this college this
university and walk the path of life
where the world is tearing you down into
yourself there's only one thing you can
do to survive hang on to who you are
inside the world will be unkind to you
it will not be able to see you
you must learn at such times to be able
to see yourself life as a created person
is like walking on a tightrope I have to
keep balancing I have to keep the
balance I begin to lose myself in my own
melodrama it is frustrating that I find
myself living up to other people's
interpretation of what I ought to be and
when faced with dissent or unappreciated
I start losing my love affair with my
own audience it becomes a tight balance
act to keep doing what I do best and not
be bothered by the reactions or the
people I'd do it for in the first place
I dance harder I caught three longer and
I pirouette on my rope stretched taut
beneath my feet and I try not to slip I
can slide but never fall and all this
while I have to keep a smile on my face
and keep signing autographs and taking
pictures and why do I do this because
I'm a human bolused trying to balance my
action an exterior reaction to my naked
show of Who I am inside
yet when I'm playing this real-life
illusion out more often than not my
honest self is sitting in the audience
applauding my performance while laughing
heartily at my own stupidity so my
little kids and friends here learn to
laugh at yourself to never become
cynical about yourself or your life
becoming cynical about your life is the
single most destructive thing you can do
for you have to remember creativity is
your gift to the world it was never
meant to be barter for anything not even
appreciation